What's your favorite Python editor?
That's one of the questions I always ask at the end of each episode.
This week, I want to shine a light on a fantastic answer to that question for Windows developers.
Visual Studio.
On this episode, you'll meet Steve Dower,
a Python core developer from Microsoft's Python Tools for Visual Studio team.
He's here to tell us all about it.
We also cover Python on Windows, Cpython, the 2016 Build Conference, and more.
This is Talk Python To Me, episode number 53, recorded April 4th, 2016.
Welcome to Talk Python To Me,
a weekly podcast on Python, the language, the libraries, the ecosystem, and the personalities.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Follow me on Twitter, where I'm @mkennedy.
Keep up with the show and listen to past episodes at talkpython.fm,
and follow the show on Twitter via at Talk Python.
This episode is brought to you by SnapCI and OpBeat.
Thank them for supporting the show on Twitter via snap underscore CI and OpBeat.
Steve, welcome to the show.
Hi, Michael. Thanks for having me.
Yeah, we've got some really cool stuff to talk about.
I'm super excited to talk about what you guys at Microsoft are up to
with bringing Python into all of your major dev products,
Visual Studio, Azure, those sorts of things.
Yeah, no, it's really exciting.
We've been working on a lot of this stuff for a number of years,
and it's really hitting a point where it's starting to come together,
and people are making good use of it.
So it's very exciting.
Yeah, I bet it is.
And we're going to totally dig into that.
But, like always, let's get started at the beginning.
Tell me your story.
How do you get into Python, programming, that sort of thing?
So my first Python experience was I got a holiday job at a startup company
that was doing medical devices.
And they had this ridiculously complicated C++ app for controlling the device
that was scriptable with Python.
So my job was basically writing the Python scripts
to control these medical devices while we were testing them.
And then after that, I started grad school,
and one of my supervisors said,
hey, you should pick up all of this code that I've done previously
and use some of that.
And I kind of looked at him and said,
is this going to help with your work?
And he's like, yeah, yeah, of course it is.
But that was all in Python.
So at that point, I was neck deep in it
and have not yet seen a reason to come out.
Yeah, it's a really nice environment, isn't it?
It's great.
It's just so flexible.
And it has so much power that users don't actually have to see
in the code that they write.
One of my favorite things is writing really complex libraries
that look incredibly simple to use.
And Python's magic, metaclasses, decorators,
makes that just really nice.
You can do a lot of stuff that people never actually see
or have to know about.
So you'd say that's kind of a different experience
than if I was writing C++ with templates and multiple inherences
and all that kind of stuff, right?
C++.
I actually put C++ in the same category.
I quite like writing templates in C++, yeah.
But it's definitely a different category from Java or C#
where you just don't have the ability to hide so much
of the implementation from what users get to see in the code.
So the interfaces are a bit more restricted in those languages
and you use what you get.
Yeah, that's for sure.
You work at Microsoft.
You said you've been there like four years or so, right?
Yep, coming up on four years,
which means following our usual tradition,
I need to provide four pounds of candy for everyone,
which I'm sure my weight-conscious colleagues
are not looking forward to,
but I'll make them indulge.
There you go.
That would probably be easier to do
if your job anniversary was around Halloween.
The stores are stocked.
Yes.
With candy.
Or just after and then get all the discounted stuff.
Exactly.
That'd be the best time.
So how'd you get there?
I actually got there through contributing to the Python Tools for Visual Studio
that I'm working on now.
That was one of the earliest open source projects to be done out of Microsoft.
It was one of the very first to accept external contributions,
and so I was contributing.
And that led to an offer of an internship,
and so they brought me out from Australia for three months.
And the nicest three months of the year in Seattle are June, July, August,
so they brought me for those three months
and got to the end and said,
what do you think?
Do you want to stay?
And I'm like, wow, it was beautiful weather.
It was sunny.
It wasn't too hot.
This sounds great.
Yeah, I'll come back.
And so, yeah, I was contributing to an open source project
that turned into a full-time job and a career
writing open source projects at Microsoft.
Yeah, that's really awesome.
I think those months that I think, you know,
I spend a lot of my time in Portland,
and we have basically the same weather.
Those are like the marketing months, right?
People fall in love with the city and the surroundings then,
and then the season of rain comes for the next six months.
Yeah, it's a complete bait and switch.
It is.
But you know what's really good is you're not driven to go outside.
You're not pulled to go out into the nice weather.
You can just focus, do some programming for six months,
and come back out when the sun shines.
Yeah, and it's almost like they deliberately put the offices somewhere
where people are going to stay in the office for longer.
Yes, it is strange that way.
Very nice.
So that's great.
I expect back in that time frame,
not so many people were hired at Microsoft to write open source.
I don't honestly know how many people were doing it at that time.
There were not many.
So my team worked really hard to get the Visual Studio support for Python
to be written as an open source project,
and many, many meetings with lawyers.
I mean, these days, to release something under the MIT license
or the Apache license is really, really easy.
But at that point, they spent months dealing with lawyers,
explaining what everything meant,
letting the lawyers do their research and find their backgrounds
and just figure out,
is it safe for us to be releasing this stuff under this license?
What's our risk?
What could go wrong?
And eventually, the team just pushed hard enough to make it happen.
And without that,
there was no open source coming out of Microsoft for the largest part.
Yeah, that's really cool.
And back then, that was such a new idea, at least in that space.
Obviously, open source had been alive and thriving,
but large corporations doing major open source
outside of a few places like Red Hat.
That was pretty rare.
So it's cool that you kind of got to be part of that seed there.
And I think in the early days in Microsoft,
a lot of their attempts to do open source
came in what I'd consider like source open rather than open source,
which means you may see the source,
but there's not the pull requests and take backs.
And this stuff wasn't really there in the early days for a lot of the projects.
Like I'm thinking of ASP.NET, for example.
Yeah, absolutely.
And some of the licensing that we did,
again, it's all about managing risk.
And clearly, at some point,
there were a couple of lawyers that,
or the entire legal department,
decided that the best way to manage that risk
would be to create licenses that had exactly the clauses
that we were concerned about.
And so we had the Microsoft public license,
Microsoft reciprocal license,
were invented and used for a while.
And fundamentally, I don't think there's anything wrong with those licenses,
apart from the fact that they weren't the ones being used by the community at that point.
And they never really became common use in the community.
So people who are used to saying,
oh, this is Apache, this is MIT, this is BSD,
I know what these mean, these are familiar,
suddenly you see an unfamiliar license.
And without being a lawyer,
going through and figuring out that it's the same is,
it's not a difficult task, but it's legal work.
And so I think people were just seeing those licenses going,
I don't really trust this,
I don't know this, I don't understand this.
Much the same as the people who created those licenses
were probably looking at the other ones going,
we don't understand these, we don't trust these.
What if, what if, what if?
Yeah, this is so different than my corporate software EULA agreement I normally have,
this MIT thing, so bizarre.
Yeah, and there's basically no language shared between the two.
If you go and actually read some of the corporate EULAs,
that nobody spends that much time looking over.
And I'm sure there's some very disappointed lawyers
who put a lot of effort into writing those,
that most people don't actually read them.
Yeah, that's too bad.
I guess probably in the early days,
those types of licenses felt just like,
oh, here's a company trying to do open source,
but they obviously don't fit in.
They just look different.
So they must not really be doing it or something.
But you guys have adopted the more mainstream stuff these days.
You've moved a lot of your source code to GitHub.
You've got more standard licenses, things like that, right?
Yeah, and at this point, as I said,
for teams that want to do open source work within Microsoft,
basically the only choice of license is MIT these days.
Apache 2 still gets some use,
and I think there's a slight movement away from that,
just in terms of what I'm seeing happen at the company.
It's all about where are people actually doing this?
How are they actually doing it?
And we've also had sort of a generation of engineers coming in
who are familiar with all this.
So basically everyone working at the company that's under 30
has used GitHub for their own projects.
They've been using proper open source.
They've been releasing their own code under open source for years already.
And so they come in,
and suddenly you've got this entire band of junior engineers
who know how it should be done,
know how everyone else expects it to be done,
and is willing to push and make it happen.
So over time, we have definitely moved to a much better place
as far as having,
as far as,
I don't like saying joining the open source community
because it sounds like it's really forced,
but we've definitely got more products
that are considered genuinely open source projects at this point.
Yeah, definitely embracing the concept
and the community of open source more.
So that's cool.
So let's talk about Visual Studio
and specifically the Python support that you guys built.
Now, I have a pretty wide range of listeners.
I suspect most of them know what Visual Studio is
and the history there,
but could you give us like the 30-second pitch
on what is Visual Studio,
where did it come from,
and why is it special that it has Python support now?
I suspect Visual Studio is probably older than me in a lot of ways.
It's a very old project that's basically
Microsoft's development platform.
So developers who need access to editors, tools,
debuggers, and all of the things that come with building
and managing and releasing software
typically find themselves inside Visual Studio.
I first started using it as Visual Basic 4,
which was a long, long time ago,
and it's grown out of that.
I don't have the full history hand here in my mind.
I mean, at that point,
I was a hobbyist and not an employee.
But these days, Visual Studio is very much the development platform.
It's the integrated environment that has all of the editors,
all of the tools,
all the languages that Microsoft supports development in
go through Visual Studio,
all of our platforms that you may want to build things for
or deploy things to.
So everything from Xbox through to phones,
which includes all phone OSs at this point.
You'll go through Visual Studio for building, debugging, deploying, testing.
It really is the home for Microsoft developers.
Yeah, so bringing Python support to that
is something that our team has been really keen to do for a long time
just because it's already the home for so many developers.
And so people who are using C++
or people who are using JavaScript
and may want an alternative for another language
have historically been switching out to other editors.
And there's no need for that.
I mean, Visual Studio has great support for so many languages
that having Python in there as well
is something that we've always been really keen to have.
So we've been working on that for years.
And at this point,
it's right up there with the other languages,
which is great to see.
Yeah, that's really great to see.
And we don't often just work in one language anymore, right?
Like, if you're going to build a web app,
you're probably doing some T-SQL.
You're doing Python.
Obviously, if you're doing it in Python,
you'll be doing some CSS, some HTML, some JavaScript.
And the fact that Visual Studio is really good at all of those things
and now Python as well,
that's really cool because it brings them all together
really in one place.
You don't have to jump around, like you said.
So can you maybe contrast, like,
the development experience with, say, like Sublime or Emacs?
Like, why would somebody who's like,
I love Sublime, start super fast, it's lightweight, it's free,
unless you pay for it.
But it'll let you use it for free, basically.
I think it's $59 officially.
And contrast that with, like, Visual Studio.
Like, how much does Visual Studio cost to get going with?
Depending on what you're planning on doing with it,
Visual Studio is probably free.
Visual Studio Community Edition was released,
what was that, a year, two years ago?
And that's still part of the current release,
is the free version.
And that's available if you're basically not a huge company
or you're working on open source software.
You can freely use Community Edition,
which has all of the features of the Professional Edition.
It doesn't have the enterprise-level features,
but that's mostly, I believe,
application lifecycle management stuff that,
well, some people absolutely love it, require it,
and we use it a lot internally at Microsoft.
It's not critical for small projects.
And certainly, if you're using GitHub
or some form of public issue tracker,
it's not actually that valuable for you,
given my understanding.
But the free version is widely available,
and that includes all functionality.
And everything from Python support,
Node.js support,
and even as we just announced the other week,
that's going to include Xamarin
for all the cross-platform work
that people want to do these days.
Yeah, Xamarin's an interesting story.
I don't want to go down that rabbit hole,
but just so people maybe don't know,
Microsoft purchased Xamarin about a month ago.
And Xamarin is basically
a development environment for taking code,
C-sharp code,
and building cross-platform apps
that feel native, right?
Like, for example, I learned at Build,
watching some of the Build videos,
doing some research on this stuff,
that Slack builds their mobile apps
with Xamarin.
That's pretty cool.
This episode is brought to you by SnapCI,
the only hosted cloud-based continuous integration
and delivery solution
that offers multi-stage pipelines
as a built-in feature.
SnapCI is built to follow best practices
like automated builds,
testing before integration,
and provides high visibility
into who's doing what.
Just connect Snap to your GitHub repo
and it automatically builds
the first pipeline for you.
It's simple enough for those
who are new to continuous integration,
yet powerful enough to run
dozens of parallel pipelines.
More reliable and frequent releases.
That's Snap.
For a free, no-obligation,
30-day trial,
just go to snap.ci slash talkpython.
Yeah, no, it's really nice to have,
like, getting back to the right ones run anywhere,
but it's a genuine run
in the place where you are
and not sort of the old
completely locked-down virtual machine run anywhere
that we had in the early days of Java.
Yeah, where you'd open an about box
and it looked clearly foreign.
Yeah, exactly.
You'd open it like a file browser
and it was obviously not part of the OS
or something like that, right?
Yep.
Compared to something like Sublime
that's sort of really lightweight,
Visual Studio,
you're going to find
a more featureful experience.
So, I know a lot of people love Sublime
because it opens quickly.
Visual Studio can open quickly,
quite often,
and they're certainly always working on improving that.
But the big difference is once you're in,
Visual Studio has
much, much better IntelliSense
for every language that it supports
than you'll find in a lightweight text editor.
And even a lot of the plugins for Emacs and VI
don't actually reach the same level of intelligence
about your code that we have in Visual Studio.
So, things like understanding decorators,
recognizing what types have gone into a tuple,
and then when you expand that out later,
we still know those types.
Things like what items have been added to a list.
So, when you iterate over that list later,
we can say, yeah,
we know it's one of these types
because these are all the things
that you've put into the list
everywhere else in your code
for this particular list.
Right.
So, you get like IntelliSense
on the item to the list
in your foreign loops,
for example, right?
Yeah.
Which demos really nicely most of the time.
But it is certainly a feature
that's very unique
to the integrated development environments,
the bigger, heavier weight tools
that I guess the current generation
of advanced text editors
we're seeing like Sublime,
like Atom,
like Notepad++,
just don't have that same level
of intelligence about the code.
I think that sums it up pretty well.
And people who listen to the show a lot
know that I kind of come down
on preferring the heavyweight IDE stuff
that really helps once you get it started
with large projects
and understanding your code.
But I know that not everyone is that way.
So, it's interesting to look at the both sides.
Yeah.
And it's definitely interesting
to see the difference
between different communities of people
when it comes to this.
Because I find so,
at Build last week,
talking to a largely Microsoft audience,
everybody knows Visual Studio,
everyone loves it,
and they don't really know Python that well.
But that means that when you get up
and show IntelliSense demos,
they're just not impressed
because they're used to Visual Studio.
And they're like,
well, you're in Visual Studio.
Of course you get IntelliSense.
Why are you showing me this?
Whereas when you go to the Python audience,
and even people who will flat out say,
I don't want to use an integrated environment,
it's too heavyweight,
it doesn't add any features,
and then you show them
that you can go to any variable
and hit F12
and see everywhere that it's been assigned,
or go to the very first place it was defined.
You can override and monkey patch functions
and see all the places
where those were changed
and where they all came from.
And suddenly they go,
oh, wow, this is amazing.
Maybe I do want the heavyweight environment
if it has this kind of magic functionality in it.
That's right.
Maybe it's worth waiting that three seconds
for it to start or whatever,
because you're going to be in it for the whole day.
So let's talk about some of the features.
Before we do,
one thing that you mentioned
in some of your conversations
in Build Conference
was sort of about Iron Python
and Python 2 and Python 3 support,
specifically CPython.
Some people listening might be thinking,
well, this is Microsoft,
it's Windows, it's Iron Python,
which is the Python
that runs on top of the .NET CLR.
Yeah, so Iron Python was a project
started at Microsoft.
I don't remember exactly when,
possibly as long as 10 years ago at this point.
When they were building
the common language runtime,
there was a small team that decided
we should build a dynamic language runtime
on top of this as well.
So effectively using the .NET platform
to do dynamic languages.
And as part of that,
they built Iron Python and Iron Ruby
to use that runtime
as, you know,
you need to make sure
that it's actually valid
by doing something useful with it.
And then when that project
eventually was not advancing
any further in that form
and some pieces were taken
and used for other things,
so people familiar
with the dynamic keyword in C#
will probably recognize
that that came out of that work.
But Iron Python and Iron Ruby
were effectively pushed out
to the community
around about 2009, 2010.
And since then,
Iron Python's been maintained externally.
Microsoft has nothing official
to do with it anymore,
though we do occasionally
contribute to it.
But it is,
it's Python on top of .NET.
And a lot of people still use it.
It gets a lot of love,
especially from people
who have sort of C#
or F Sharp assemblies
that they want to use from Python
or they want to test from Python
because it's so natural
to just load those up
with an import statement
and call into it.
But there is a big assumption
that being Microsoft,
that's all we care about.
And that's absolutely
not the case at this stage
and hasn't been for six years.
When that project was released
and we started
on the Visual Studio support,
it was really, really clear
that 99 plus percent
of Python developers
were using CPython
and there was just no way
that we could cut those people out
and say,
well, you've all got to switch
to .NET to use this.
That would have been just ridiculous.
So we didn't do it.
Yeah, and the guys
with things like NumPy,
they're like,
you know, I kind of like this library.
I'd like to see integration
with this package
and I don't want to just
do some .NET thing.
So obviously, right?
Yeah, and NumPy is hard enough
to build on Windows already
that we wouldn't want
to be forcing people
to have to build it
as part of IronPython.
Though we did try that for a while.
There was a project
to get that working
that eventually
just ran into too many issues.
But yeah, CPython is
sort of the main star of the show.
for us.
So the Visual Studio support
extends from CPython 2.5
through to 3.5
with every version in between
and 32-bit, 64-bit
and everything from
debugging, profiling,
IntelliSense.
We have all the
context-sensitive keywords
like async and await.
We handle all the future imports
for CPython properly
and all the other interpreters
are supported as well.
And frankly,
they tend to come off
a bit like a second thought
compared to CPython.
We're very much focused on
the same area that the entire
Python community
is focused on.
So PyPy, Jython,
IronPython,
we test,
we use a bit,
but CPython gets the bulk
of the work.
I kind of feel like
the entire community
is just going to use CPython
unless there's some
huge pressure
from a performance problem
or some other type of thing
that forces them to
go and find some other
interpreter or runtime
like PyPy,
which is really cool,
but it's just not the standard.
So you've got to have
a really good reason
to do that, right?
Yeah, and frankly,
I'm a little disappointed
that Jython didn't get
a nice big boost
from Minecraft integration.
I was really hoping
that was going to
push it a long way along,
but that doesn't seem
to have happened.
I know a few people
have done it,
but that could have been
a lot of fun.
Yeah, yeah, too bad.
Let's talk about
some of the project types
and types of apps
that you can build
with Visual Studio
Python support.
So you guys have
web apps, right?
Yeah, so a project
in Visual Studio,
for those who don't use it,
is essentially
just a collection of files.
You can think of it
as these are the files
that all relate
to this one project.
It's roughly equivalent
to these are the ones
that I check into
source control
or the things that I may
want to edit
within Visual Studio,
but a project also includes
things like launch options,
debugging options,
and so there's a few
sort of categories
of those that we like
to start with.
So web projects
quite often have
different launch options.
So rather than just
typing Python name
of the script,
you'll do
python-m bottle
name of the script,
or python manage.py run
server to get it going.
So they have
different launch options.
So we provide
some projects
that pre-configure
those effectively
so that when you go
and hit F5
to start running,
it's already set up
for running
that web project.
but the project itself
is not actually
that constraining
and it's quite easy
to configure
a regular project
to be a Python project
and we've actually
got some future work
coming,
which I think we'll
talk about future work
in a bit,
that we'll just get rid
of projects completely.
Oh, how interesting.
Okay.
Well, that sounds
really cool.
So if I have
like a Flask app
and it's got
all of its templates,
does it understand,
does Visual Studio
understand like
the Jinja 2
or Chameleon templates?
So we don't have
Jinja 2 yet.
A while back,
we invested in
Django templates
and have that there.
So if you're using
Django and using
the Django template syntax,
now this is before
they offered
Jinja 2 as an option,
then you'll get
IntelliSense
within the template file,
you'll be able to debug,
you can set a breakpoint
in the template
and it'll stop
and you can step
through your template
as it's being generated
on your local machine.
Yeah, the debugging
of the templates,
that's pretty awesome
because sometimes
when template binding
goes wrong,
you're just like,
why is this not working?
It's really hard to understand
like when it's handed off
to the template engine,
like what's going on anymore?
So that's pretty cool.
Yeah, and definitely
when things go wrong,
you don't always get
the nicest stack trace
out of it.
So being able to stop
execution just before
something gets rendered
incorrectly and inspect
and see what's going on
is really helpful.
Yeah, a lot of times
it's kind of like
there was something wrong
with your template.
Yeah.
Or your data
going to the template.
Sorry, because it's just
the call stack
of like the template parsing.
So that doesn't help.
Yeah.
Sort of generic
Jinja 2 support
is on our wish list
of things we'd love to do.
We briefly investigated
updating the stuff
we have for Django
to support Jinja
and it's not quite feasible yet.
Django,
original style Django templates
were mostly handling
with regexes
because they have
a more restricted format.
Jinja 2,
you can't do that.
Jinja,
we need like a full
HTML
slash Jinja parser
to be able to
figure out
how it all works.
So that's on our wish list.
We'd love to have it
and we just
haven't had a chance
to get to it yet
because turns out
writing a parser
is a big task.
Yeah, I'm sure that it is.
So if somebody's out there
listening,
they're like,
I could totally
write that parser.
Do you guys take
contributions and stuff?
Absolutely.
GitHub.com
slash Microsoft
slash P-T-V-S.
That's Python tools
for Visual Studio
and yeah,
come let us know
that you're interested.
We're happy to help you out
and we'll accept pull requests.
We've already accepted one
for our next big release.
So people who are looking
for brace completion,
that was contributed
by an external person
who basically just came along
and said,
I really want this.
I'm willing to do it.
Here's the code.
What do you think?
Oh, lovely.
This episode is brought
to you by OpBeat.
OpBeat is application
monitoring for developers.
It's performance monitoring,
error logging,
release tracking,
and workflow
in one simple product.
OpBeat is integrated
with your code base
and makes monitoring
and debugging
of your production apps
much faster
and your code better.
OpBeat is free
for an unlimited
number of users
and starting today,
December 1st,
OpBeat is announcing
that their Flask support
is graduating from beta
to a full commercial product.
Visit opbeat.com
slash Flask
to get started today.
So one thing that I saw
that you guys can do,
I think it's sort of special
because the deep relationship
with C++ and C
and Visual Studio.
Like,
my first experience
with Visual Studio
was with Visual C++
1.52
back in like 1994
or something.
So it's been C++
capable for quite a while.
And one of the things
you can do
is you can like
mix mode,
you called it
mix mode debugging,
right?
That sounded pretty cool.
Can you talk about that?
Yeah, so it's actually
one of our most popular features.
It's unique to Visual Studio.
We're not aware
of any other
development environment
out there that can do this.
Though GDB has some extensions
that get kind of close.
What it essentially is
is when you have
Python code calling
into a C module,
so one that you've written
and built yourself,
when we have
the debugging information,
we can give you
a debugging view
of both the Python
and the C code simultaneously.
So you can set
a breakpoint in the C code.
You can set
breakpoints in the Python code.
You can inspect variables
in each one
and see,
so from the C code,
oh, I've got a PyObject star.
If I hover over it
and have a look,
it'll show me
what it would look like
as a Python object,
whether, you know,
a list of items
or a tuple
or a dictionary
and step between
the two different worlds.
And so you end up
with this call stack
that goes Python,
Python, Python,
Python, C, C, C, C,
Python, Python, Python,
which is amazingly helpful
when you're trying
to debug native modules.
It's actually something
that I had to do a lot
when I first started
and we didn't have this feature.
So I know how incredibly
painful it is to do
without having
this sort of layer on top
that shows you
all the actual Python values
that you'd be missing otherwise.
That is super helpful.
So I guess
anyone out there
is listening
who's writing
some sort of C extension
and wants to help
debugging it,
you know,
try the free Visual Studio
version with Python tools
included.
That'd be awesome.
So you want to talk
about some of the
other project types?
one of the things
that seems like
Microsoft is up to
these days,
last four,
three or four years,
ever since such a
Nadella's taken over,
I guess,
is you guys seem
to be all in on Azure.
And so you could actually
have support for Python
and sort of deploying
straight out of Visual Studio
into like a web app
running on Azure, right?
Yeah, so Azure web apps,
kind of the highest level,
most managed platform,
I guess,
for deploying websites.
It's really,
really quick to just push
up the code for a site
to,
and now you have
an active website.
So there's no setting
up machines,
there's no installing
web servers
or doing some
machine level configuration.
It is within a minute
of saying,
I would like a website.
You've got a website,
which is really,
really cool.
And so the support
that we have
inside Visual Studio
for that
just brings that down.
It's just bringing
the click count down
because you can
do all of this
through FTP
or you can do it
through via a Git repository.
And then there's
sort of the one click,
I have my files here
on my machine,
I want them on that machine,
just go and do it
and we'll go off and do it.
I really like the websites
that you guys have in Azure.
Like if I need a little
small website
that I can just spin up
really quick,
my first thought often
is just go to Azure
because there's
nothing to set up.
And you can have
up to 10 sites,
I think,
for free,
like 100% free forever.
That's pretty awesome.
Yeah,
I think 10's the limit there.
And I mean,
if you want to try it
without even signing up,
then you can go to,
I think it's
try.azurewebsites.net
and we'll give you
a free site for an hour
without any sign up,
no credit cards
or anything at all.
We'll just give you a site,
we'll give you
a Git repository
and so you can push
directly to the site
and have a website running.
And there's a whole lot
of templates in there
if you want to start
from a Django
or a Bottle
or a Flask site
or if you're interested
in doing it in PHP
or Node.js,
we have like,
all of the languages
are supported for websites
and so that
try.azurewebsites.net
is just a really quick way
to get a website going
and see whether
it does what you want it to.
another one that I saw
that I have no experience with
so you'll have to tell me
a little bit about it
is when I was playing
with the Python projects,
I saw that you have
a Windows Internet of Things core,
maybe Windows core
for Internet of Things,
as a Python project type.
What's that?
There's a team
at Microsoft
at the moment
that's been working
on what's known
as Windows IoT core.
It's basically
a version of Windows
that is really,
really stripped down.
It's still sort of
the latest builds
of Windows
but there's a lot
of unnecessary things removed
and it's really designed
to be run
on like Raspberry Pi 2
or sort of
about that scale devices
for sort of
high level
Internet of Things
type tasks.
So it's not
the little tiny
microcontroller device
that's just got
a sensor attached to it
but something bigger
where maybe you've got
a running process
that's going to pull down
a whole lot of data
off the Internet,
do some processing,
display it on
an attached
screen or device
of some sort
and that platform
has a slightly
different app
deployment model
than on like
the Raspberry Pi OS
or some of the other
IoT things.
So it is running Windows.
One of the big benefits
of that is the security
you get out of it
in terms of
you can't just run
unsigned code on it,
you can't jump outside
of the sandbox
that the code is running
within
and it has a lot
of those benefits
and what that means
is that you need
to go through
a couple of extra steps
to deploy code to it
in the first place.
So that template
is actually very different
from all the other
templates we have.
but it is a good
starting point for IoT.
You jump into that,
you get a special
version of Python
that we had to rebuild
so it's Python 3.5
rebuilt to run on
IoT Core.
I believe something
like 95%
of the functionality
is there.
There's a few features
that had to be removed
because they would
not work within
the sandbox
that's provided
but within that
you can set up
a background service,
it can do network
access,
it can do processing
and all of that
will then be
easily deployed
to Raspberry Pi 2
or any device,
I forget the other
ones that it will run on
but anything that
Windows IoT Core
will run on
can run those
Python applications
and from within
Visual Studio
you have sort of
that one click
deploy and run,
you can F5
to deploy and debug
and we'll use
our remote debugger
to attach to it
and you'll get
the full Visual Studio
experience of stepping
through,
inspecting variables
while running
on a little
tiny device.
That sounds awesome.
I should check that out.
Yeah, and not to
exclude the other ones,
if you are working
on an original
Raspberry Pi
or a different OS
then Visual Studio
has remote debugging
for Python
so it's a little
module that
you can put
with your code
on any platform
on clusters
of Raspberry Pis
and use Visual Studio
to do their debugging
by connecting to it
from their Windows machine.
That I haven't
got to play with
but it sounds
really handy.
Awesome.
Can you give us
a glimpse
of maybe
something that's coming
that people don't know about
like a feature
that's under development
that's pretty cool?
Basically everything
that we do
that we're actually doing
is going to show up
on our GitHub site
so if people go
and look at the commits
there you can see
what's definitely
coming sometime soon.
There's a lot of things
that we talk about
that don't always
make it past
the talking stage
so it's kind of
hard to say
from this huge list
of stuff we say
yeah we'd love
to do this
we'd love to do this
which ones will make it
to the stage
of we're actually doing it.
One thing that is
getting very close
to that second step
and is support
for Visual Studio Code
so people who
may not be familiar
with that
recently
in fact about a year ago
Microsoft made the first release
of Visual Studio Code
which is a cross-platform
version of Visual Studio
it's lighter weight
it doesn't have a lot
of the advanced functionality yet
but it's much more comparable
to something like
Sublime Text
in terms of
I have a directory of code here
I just need to jump around
in it a bit
I still want good
IntelliSense
I still want the ability
to navigate
based off
code semantics
rather than simple searching
I need git integration
I want F5 to debug
and we're at the point
where
99% certain
that we'll be committing
to
like really beefing up
the Python support there
it has basic support
for a lot of languages
including Python
but there's
not yet any debugging
there's
very limited
or no IntelliSense
and launching
is not
quite there yet
so there's
a range of things
to work on
there's currently
a community extension
that's doing it
and we're thrilled
to see that
the community
has said
hey we care enough
about Python
to make this happen
regardless
yeah that's great
do you know
the name of the extension
so people can search for it
or I can link to it
the extension's Python
so
if you just
X install Python
from within Visual Studio Code
you'll get it
it will make it difficult
for us
if we put out
another Python extension
because we'll have to
pick a different name
oh yeah they really
grabbed the main name
didn't they
yeah they went and took it
so there's always
a possibility
that we'll get in touch
with the guy who's created
and say hey
you've already got
users
you know
everyone already loves
this one
can we contribute to it
and then you know
maybe we don't end up
with a
an official Microsoft one
but we really beef up
the community owned
and driven one
already with
with all of the stuff
that we've got
from Visual Studio proper
we'll try and bring that
over to Visual Studio Code
and get that out there
so
not quite sure
how that looks right now
when it's going to be available
but it's definitely
something that
is coming
and so there will be
cross-platform
Visual Studio Code
Python support
coming soon
yeah that's awesome
it's nice to see
Visual Studio Code
coming along
and with the whole
.NET Core stuff
and I talked to
Brett Cannon
he was on show 49
about
some of the
the pigeon work
that you guys
are doing
involving .NET Core
and cross-platform
so all those things
are coming together
really nicely
but let's take it
back to Windows
for just a second
so
as somebody
who teaches
Python
I want to say
thank you
for building
the new
Windows installer
for CPython
oh my god
that has been
such a nightmare
that to try to
you know
people come to class
they've got some
crappy old laptop
they got from their company
you know
it doesn't have
Python on it
and they want to get started
and they forgot to check
the little box
put this in my path
and it's just
oh
you know
there were so many
little gotchas
and you recently
updated that
in a pretty major way
right?
yeah
so
what was it
PyCon
last year
I think
or
might have been
the year before
I think
the
the person
who was
responsible
for producing
the builds
of CPython
for Windows
effectively
resigned
and said
I've
you know
I've got other things
I need to step away
for a bit
so if someone else
wants to take over
then they're more
than welcome to
and
thinking it wouldn't
be that much work
I put my hand up
which
turned out to be
a silly thing to do
but that's what I did
and so since then
I've been
largely responsible
for
excuse me
for a lot of
Python on Windows
one of the things
that I've been
really keen to do
for a long time
and was
kind of going to
contribute it anyway
was to
rewrite the installer
and
I mean
frankly I'm still
not entirely happy
with where it's at
but it's not
something that you
can change
dramatically too often
but one of the
big
well I can tell you
it is a much
nicer experience
than it has been
so I'm
I can definitely
say that
so people
who have
tried to
like set up
Python on
Windows before
and be like
oh here goes
this thing
it almost
works
it's a lot
nicer
so
it may have
ways to go
but it's
great
yeah
and I did
achieve
two of the
big things
that I wanted
to do
which was
moving the
default
installation
directory
into
somewhere
more secure
because
historically
if you
put Python
in the root
directory
of your
system drive
anyone on
that machine
can write
to it
and that
then means
that
someone
who's
not
an
administrative
user
can install
whatever
package
they want
and then
if someone
who is an
admin
runs
that
Python
at all
they're going
to run
that code
that's been
installed
by someone
who shouldn't
have privileges
to install
it for them
so that was
always a security
concern
for a lot
of Windows
users
a lot
of corporations
and so by
moving it
either into
program files
or into the
user's install
directory
that mitigates
that attack
vector
which is
a real big
improvement
for a lot
of people
the other
thing is
a proper
per user
install
so previously
if you
installed
Python
you could
say
install
it
just
for me
but you
still had
to be an
administrator
to actually
install it
so one of
the big
big changes
that I made
in that
installer
was so
if you
choose that
and then you
choose not
to install
the launcher
for all
users
then you
don't need
to be an
admin
at all
and we'll
just go
ahead and
install
Python
without ever
asking you
to elevate
so it's
great for
students who
may not have
full control
of their
machine
people
working at
companies
where the
machines are
locked down
and they're
not allowed
to make
changes to
it
you can
still install
Python
3.5
on those
machines
because we
don't require
to actually
make changes
to the
machine
we just
put all
of Python
into a
directory
that you
have full
access to
already
yeah
I've run
into that
problem
more than
once
that people
even though
they're
professional
developers
at a
company
they're
still not
given
enough
control
of their
machines
to
make
system
level
changes
which is
kind of
ridiculous
but it's
great that
that's
all there
so very
cool
let's
talk about
build
for a
little
bit
so
this is
kind of
like
Microsoft's
major
developer
conference
and
you
were
there
I saw
you were
giving
some
talks
on
Python
you were
kind of
spreading
the
good
word
of
Python
saying
look I
know
a lot
of you
guys
here
that
guy
is
doing
C++
you guys
are
all
doing
.NET
but
maybe
you should
consider
Python
can you
maybe
give us
your
impressions
of
what you
guys
announce
this
year
and
how
did
your
session
go
build
always
has
a lot
of
exciting
announcements
and
even
for
employees
we
don't
know
a lot
of
the
stuff
that's
going
to
be
announced
there
so
we're
all
watching
the
keynotes
the same
as
everyone
else
and
seeing
all
the
exciting
stuff
coming
out
I'm
still
waiting
for
the
day
when
we
get
to
make
some
big
Python
announcements
from
the
keynote
stage
but
that's
probably
a couple
of
years
away
still
at
this
point
but
I'm
hoping
for
that
but
yeah
there's
definitely
so much
coming
out
I love
the idea
of
conversation
bots
I
really
like
that
idea
of
making
so many
of
these
interactions
more
natural
I
definitely
feel
like
we've
gone
from
where
years
ago
you'd
call
up
a
hotel
to
book
no
one
does
that
anymore
you
go
to
a
third
party
website
that
will
do
the
booking
for
you
and
it's
gotten
very
impersonal
and
I
don't
actually
see
that
undoing
completely
but
having
the
sort
of
conversational
option
to do
something
like
that
where
it
can
use
context
because
it
knows
about
you
having
I
guess
an
interactive
dialogue
to
achieve
a
task
as
opposed
to
where
in
step
one
two
step
three
wizard
kind
of
format
feels
like
a
great
step
into
a
really
exciting
future
yeah
it
is
pretty
cool
and
just
to
kind
of
take
a
step
back
for
listeners
who
maybe
didn't
see
the
you
guys
announced
this
thing
called
a
bot
framework
which
I
then
announced
it
and
said
this
is
for
C
sharp
and
no
JS
bots
and
so
of
course
the
first
thing
I
did
is
went
off
to
write
a
button
Python
did
it
work
did
it
worked
great
the
documentation
is
not
quite
thorough
enough
to
make
that
easy
for
people
to
do
because
the
first
step
is
install
this
library
or
install
this
library
and
until
we
have
a
Python
version
of
that
library
which
is
something
that
I'm
really
keen
to
do
now
it's
not
quite
trivial
going
but
even
without
that
I
managed
to
get
a
bot
going
that
you
can
chat
with
through
the
framework
and
so
then
the
nice
thing
about
fitting
into
the
framework
connectors
so
it's
instructions
are
provided
for
connecting
that
bot
up
through
telegram
twitter
through
twilio
so
many
of
these
services
that
if
you
want
to
interact
with
it
by
email
or
by
phone
call
or
sms
you
can
just
do
that
and
so
that's
a
really
cool
thing
about
that
framework
is
you
write
a
bot
once
and
then
you
can
reference
it
from
all
of
these
services
that
support
bots
in
some
form
yeah
it
looks
really
cool
and
for
the
data
scientists
out
there
listening
the
back
end
stuff
you
guys
are
doing
with
machine
learning
and
natural
language
processing
there's
a lot
of
really
cool
semantic
understanding
of
written
text
and
stuff
so
I
think
that
was
one
of
the
really
interesting
ones
you
guys
did
a
bunch
of
open
source
announcements
so
we
talked
about
Microsoft
becoming
more
open
source
this
was
absolutely
evident
there
that
was
super
cool
to
see
but
one
that
surprised
coming
at
all
was
Ubuntu
on
Windows
tell me
what that
is
I
don't
think
anyone
saw
that
one
coming
I
wouldn't
have
been
surprised
if
the
CEO
whenever
they
went
and
told
Satya
hey
we're
going
to
announce
this
at
build
if
he
wasn't
completely
shocked
out
of
his
seat
no
it
really
cool
it
is
like
so
I've
had
a
chat
with
those
guys
and
it
really
is
such
a
nice
thin
layer
on
top
of
the
Windows
APIs
that
you'd
never
see
so
it's
not
like
Sigwin
where
you
have
a
different
set
of
libraries
to
build
against
it's
a
kernel
shim
so
everything
is
already
built
for
Ubuntu
and
it
is
literally
we
just
copy
the
binaries
over
and
every
time
they
go
to
call
into
the
kernel
that
gets
intercepted
and
rewritten
into
the
Windows
kernel
calls
but
it's
completely
transparent
you don't
have to
rebuild
anything
you don't
have to
change
references
and
so
when
you
get
bash
and
you
just
get
into
and
start
calling
stuff
it's
all
the
exact
same
elf
binaries
as
you'd
have
on
a
machine
that
has
Linux
all
the
way
through
instead
of
being
this
layer
on
top
of
Windows
and
the
thing
that
really
blew
me
away
is
I
didn't
test
this
but
I
saw
the
blog
post
the
performance
is
apparently
right
up
there
with
a
native
Linux
machine
which
is
incredible
that's
really
awesome
so
people
who
love
their
Linux
tools
which
a lot
of
Python
developers
do
this
is
coming
to
Windows
basically
in
a
native
sense
right
what's
the
timeline
did
you
catch
that
no
I
didn't
catch
the
timeline
but
I
understand
it's
in
the
current
preview
releases
so
if
you're
part
of
the
Windows
Insider
program
then
you
should
either
have
a
build
with
it
or
you'll
soon
be
getting
a
build
that
will
since
it
was
coming
with
the
anniversary
update
of
Windows
I
expect
that's
when
it'll
come
out
but
certainly
there
are
early
builds
available
I've
used
one
but
I
get
access
to
the
daily
builds
but
the
insider
builds
are not
that far
behind
they're
typically
only
three to
four
days
behind
what
we
have
access
to
as
employees
so
there
should
be
one
out
there
at
this
point
already
though
I
haven't
checked
so
I
could
be
wrong
but
it's
very
cool
yeah
I'll
be sure
to link
to that
in the
show notes
as well
all right
Steve we
just have
a few
more
minutes
so
time
for
a couple
of
closing
questions
this
one
is
going
to be
a
softball
for you
what's
your favorite
Python
editor
Visual Studio
that's
awesome
isn't that
the answer
everyone gives
yeah
that's
well I
am
trying to
spread
the word
I
think
it's
great
what
you guys
are doing
there
so
congratulations
on that
and
I always
ask
you know
there's
so many
packages
on the
Python
package
index
on PyPI
at least
75,000
last time
I checked
the number
there's
got to be
a bunch
that you use
that maybe
people don't
know about
you like
you should
check this
out
it's
awesome
what
one's
yours
that
comes
to
mind
well
okay
so
leaving
out
the
ones
that
I've
written
myself
because
that
seems
a little
unfair
though
I do
like
the
project
Oxford
library
which
does
text-to-speech
and speech
recognition
and natural
language
understanding
using
what's
now called
the Cortana
intelligence
suite
that's a
fun little
demo
one that
I wrote
probably
and certainly
if you
asked all
my colleagues
I talk
about
requests
all the
time
and
that's
largely
because
I keep
seeing
code
that's
using
htplib
and
my answer
is always
just use
requests
please
just use
requests
stop
using
anything
that isn't
requests
so
that's
almost
certainly
my
favorite
library
and
if
you
have
used
htplib
stop
using
it
and
use
requests
and
you'll
see
why
okay
final call
to
action
how do
people
get
started
with
this
whole
thing
that
you
guys
built
so
aka.ms
slash
python
is
our
sort
of
short
link
and
that
will
get
you
to
right
now
it
gets
you
to
the
visual
studio
page
about
Python
support
depending
on
when
you
come
back
and
listen
to
this
podcast
it
may
be
pointing
somewhere
else
but
that's
always
going
to
point
the
best
landing
page
for
whatever
Python
stuff
is
going
on
at
Microsoft
probably
the
second
one
is
aka.ms
slash
python
blog
which
is
our
team's
blog
so
we're
posting
about
once
a
week
on
everything
from
what
are
we
doing
at
Microsoft
with
Python
what
is
going
on
in
the
community
what
some
ways
of
improving
your
coding
style
and
that's
where
you'll
get
the
latest
news
about
whatever
Python
stuff
is
going
on
at
Microsoft
I set
it up
the other
day
on my
fresh new
version
of
Windows
and
it
was
no
problem
nice
and easy
just
install
Visual Studio
Python
tools
and
file
new
project
pick
your
Python
flavor
and
go
right
it's
very
nice
I'd
also
like
to
add
one
more
thing
people
out there
listening
who
haven't
checked
out
what
Microsoft
is
doing
for
a while
you
should
check out
the
build
keynotes
I'll link
to them
in the
show notes
there's
some
really
different
stuff
happening
at
Microsoft
than
5-10
years
ago
yeah
it's
very
exciting
I love
that we're
really
getting
innovating
again
definitely
congrats
on all
the stuff
you guys
are doing
Steve
it was
great
to have
you
on
the
show
thanks
for
giving
us
an
this
has
been
another
episode
of
talk
python
to
me
today's
guest
was
Steve
Dower
and this
episode
has been
sponsored
by
snapcii
and
opbeat
thank you
guys
for
supporting
the
show
snapcii
is
modern
continuous
integration
and
delivery
build
test
and
deploy
your
code
directly
from
github
all
in
your
browser
with
debugging
docker
and
parallelism
included
try them
for free
at
snap.cii
slash
talk
python
opbeat
is
mission
control for
your
python
web
applications
keep an eye on errors, performance, profiling, and more in your Django, Flask, and even pyramid web apps.
Tell them thanks for supporting the show on Twitter where they're at opbeat.
I use both of these products on all the talk python web properties and you should check them out too.
They're really excellent. Seriously.
Are you or a colleague trying to learn python?
Have you tried boring books and videos that just cover the topic point by point?
Check out my online course python jumpstart by building 10 apps at training.talkpython.fm.
The reviews so far have been fantastic.
You can find the links from the show at talkpython.fm/episodes slash show slash 53.
And be sure to subscribe to the show.
Open your favorite podcatcher and search for Python.
We should be right at the top.
You can also find the iTunes and direct RSS feeds in the footer of the website.
Our theme music is Developers, Developers, Developers by Corey Smith, who goes by Smix.
You can hear the entire song on talkpython.fm.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
As always, thank you so much for listening.
I really appreciate it.
Smix, it's time to take us out of here.
It's dating with my voice.
There's no norm that I can feel within.
Haven't been sleeping.
I've been using lots of rest.
I'll pass the mic back to who rocked it best.
Thank you.